it's really incredible to watch
something become bigger than myself
I used to call quiet my song why it is
now our song
[Music]
my name is Connie Lim and I go by milk
as a recording artist and I think my job
is to help heal people I got involved
with music by playing piano and singing
and writing my first song age 7 my
mission with my music is to empower and
to heal I used to have an eating
disorder and I'm a product of abuse and
so when I wrote songs I was able to
digest some of my pain I'm constantly
chasing the hi of writing a song that
makes me feel like I can breathe more my
song quiet is about that gentle rage
that I felt whenever I felt stereotyped
or oppressed or controlled or even when
I was doing it to myself
I went to DC to participate in the DC
woman's March and I recruited a bunch of
women who lived in the DC area to sing
my song with me
when we were singing on the streets of
DC we did seven flash mobs and I thought
to myself this is my calling my calling
is to facilitate these groups of women
to come together and sing together
because singing can create endless
bionis
[Music]
within two days the video of us
performing had 14 million views my life
is completely changed I've signed with
Atlantic Records I get messages from
women all over the world saying that
when they can't get out of bed they'll
play the song so they get out of bed I
think that's amazing
I'm definitely gonna continue down this
path because it's so fulfilling and so
empowering for me and for other people
I'm empowering women and men and all
genders in between and helping people
heal and that's exactly what my purpose
is
[Music]
you